i couldn't stand up in front of a crowd
like everything was just intimidating to
me
you know i was a fish out of water
they're going to think i'm a crazier
with the camera asking them can you pose
for me this is for the yearbook oh you
should join you should join the band i'm
like i don't know you know
i mean i've always been short so i'm
just like thinking about the others
watching me
i can't even count how nervous i was
like the year before i was i don't know
how to explain i feel free and then make
it creative like anybody
there's no reason to go if you're not
going to give it your all
it's really hard studying for the sat
because especially as a senior because
you have so many things to do
whether you want to do it or you don't
it all starts now
i don't feel confident enough i practice
more
some people come in talented
but that's not enough
you have to say goals that you have to
hit i will put 110 because this is what
i want to do this is my goal and i want
to accomplish it
look at me now i'm
number one i'm in charge
to the rear
heart
[Music]
if it's state championship or test like
the s.a.t it all comes from your
practice what you've been doing before
and you shouldn't be as scared to do it
the second time because you already know
what to expect
the point of doing that is so your brain
has that muscle memory that like a
second nature kind of thing
you got it you remember this like the
game goes silent
[Music]
[Music]
in the moment you don't really realize
that shift of confidence
you've trained so hard to know
what to expect and then once you see it
it's like wow
[Music]